as a kid i had the dream of winning an  olympic gold medal  youngest male swimmer to qualify for a  us  team  [Applause]  28 medals 23 goals  we are revisiting every single one of  michael phelps's olympic finals  30 in all i knew if i glided there on  that last stroke i lose the race  he gets it done again the race of the  century  these guys swam the race so much  different than i did back then  when did the goggles happen they're  already done they're filled up wardrobe  malfunctioned  i remember sharing that medal with her  through a chain-link fence  he said mom look what i did  i wanted to do something that no one  else has ever done before  now there were some amazing parts some  sad parts i wouldn't change anything  you